uomo io non posso dire niente minuti
l'intera vita sommitale e oggi challenge
epica vi ricordate la 3 colore di colla
slide challenge ferrari faremo però con
tutti i vertici sono un prossimo curioso
di vedere che i colori ci capiteranno
trattati tricolori e non solo ai tre
andremo a pescare un colore a festa
bendati e dovremo aggiungerlo al nostro
slime alla fine del turno mischieremo
tutti e tre i colori e arriveremo lo
slime e vincerà chi avrà lo slime più
bello soprattutto del colore più bello
ma non sempre alla fine del v che
dovrete votare qua nel sondaggio se
vinco io se dice vitale ma che è una
bellezza delusione messori as mr e mi
raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace e
consigliati seppure che altre sale se
volete vedere nel canale
fornirò bruno trentin primo giorno
vediamo che inizia cazzo corri bacio
cassaforte ci fosse un forno ma allora
vivendo io e nel frattempo evitare può
mischiare i colori
prego graziano proprio curioso di vedere
se aspetta vero perché siccome sono
tanti io devo sempre mischiarli bene
sono curiosa di vedere se questa volta
fa eco il verde se massa e curioso lui
mi sembra strano che la maledizione del
verde funzionerà perché ci sono troppi
colori ci sono troppi i colori di tutti
i colori verdi chiamo io me ne di
prendere in rotta
spero di prendere un rosati ok
e'ormai ostacoli quali solamente
influisce ok stata fatto sei questo se
voi lo puoi cambiare no secondo me
conoscendoti hai messo tutti i verdi al
centro perché sai che il pesco dal
centro e colori bene vivessi in fondo
lontano contando che io non prenderei
mai quindi penso di aver preso un bel
colore mi vuoi bene
terrore
diciamo che non avevi proprio azzeccato
visto che il verde parlaci alla fine il
vero e proprio centro e al centro almeno
un marrone metallizzato magari lo
renderà gontero gold to quali colori non
vorresti io non vorrei il celeste no il
dr io vorrei il verde non per lei in
rosa ma non è vero guarda secondo me tu
non vorresti qualcosa che mischiando lo
si può trasformare in un marrone oggi
grigio anche crisi ci diamo così chiuso
per questo cos'è
voglio guardare prima terra diciamo che
questo hai preso la ragione questo
venendo però seconda di come lo mischi
potrebbe diventare marrone non posso
fare solo possa scendere altro volto
questo colore mi piace torna a parlare
di questo cuore dei nostri brand italia
mi interessa io faccio un colore
challenge di oggi farò un colore di
nicola lallo però io voglio fare sono
più colore ragazzi diteglielo poi ma
anzi può ma se non posso fare solo 22
colori diciamo lena stavo se sarai
fortunato a beccare niente lanzoni ma
non penso proprio che sarà io voglio
fare due dello stesso colore giallo
ecco qua il mio marrone pour homme bene
un marrone metallizzato quindi potrebbe
diventare un
l'am dorato uno slam pronto 13
metallizzato line cassetto diventare
vediamo un po che per colore matti che
bello guarda è anche un po brillantinato
e ora o mai più bronzo signora color
terra bagnata
secondo me questo sarà un bel colore una
volta mischia le anche berlino si sta
lamentando il sottosistema gelato però
non piace perché lui guardiamo il mio
bellissimo mater bi color arancione pare
però un sacco perché stupendo
lunedì di trattare e mi piace ho deciso
io voglio fare il mare dello slang sono
di questo colore o in spiace ma spero
proprio che beccherai un verdolino
cercheremo di vento molto belle ma
grande gioia perché bel colore a
rebellin è stupendo bravo
grasso un cenno questa volta a dei dati
sono beccato canta una canzone
[Musica]
allora io devo cercare di prendere
l'arancione
allora secondo me è spostato solo questi
qui centrali
però non mi ricordo dell'estate secondo
me c'era un bottiglione grande vediamo
pack che dovreste aver privato il medico
non è quello che tocchi che devi
prendere per forza e anche agazzi e sei
indeciso tra questa questo fare dei due
aree chan e io non posso dire niente
gravità rosso arancio estranei
[Applauso]
adesso arancione giallo dai sei stato
abbastanza fortunato perché non è che
loro vita prima mente avevo preso questo
sei rosso ma forse stava miglior rosso
allora promosso con la ragione che ha
ben chiaro la rotta
sì spero sempre di beccare in rosa per
mese l'n8 oppure jazz un gol oppure
[Musica]
sembrata come mai esserne sicuro non è
che mercati colori e la giapponese ha
rilasciato hai ragione tu vuoi dire
ancora che non puoi sapere tutti ora non
è tutto questo mio anno con un certo vai
questa rosa rosa rosa pro da roma che
sicura che quello rosa rosa rosa rosa
roma sei sicura che cosa l'avrà vi
aspettate
ma ci sta pure bellico per qualora ciò
non mi tenevo davvero a bibbiano botte
al mio film sul verde polizia acqua e
poi uno ma dietro delle altre
[Musica]
rossi uomo anche non mettere dentro il
secondo più durante qualsiasi micheloni
ecco qua la mia col lavoro con il
glister anche viva se l'ultimo colore
non mi esce una schifezza
potrei riuscire a fare un bellissimo
slime cose metallizzato
secondo me ti lascio la schifezza non è
vero sono bellino il no secondo me non
uscirò interrotto
certo lo so e lo diventa anche liberato
terrana ferretti bello è diventata
glitterata vino bellissima adesso sempre
proprio terracotta guarda sei geloso ma
che bello che il mio ne vediamo ora con
il giallo come diventa prendiamo
aggiungiamo questo giallo canarino
carissimo marino
vediamo gruppo blu di ogni mezzo tanti
ma è diventato già le diamo vediamo che
coloro uscirà fuori
che paura resto è diventato color senape
colore strano visti che diventa un
mostarda ne è costati di nuovo no è un
corona renzone 3 molto più chiaro 1 giro
6 stata comunque fortunato e sarebbe
l'ultimo tornati capito in collane
amedeo è un arancione un po strano però
dai peggiori sistemiamo tutto qui
l'ultimo turno questo è il giorno più
importante perché potrebbe rovinare
completamente il nostro time ha pure
migliorare nel tuo caso che mia daily
mio bellissimo vorrei dire siete così
ben omar in mente ma che cosa sta cosa
terra terra mischiata quell'inizio e
grande è bravissimo e con del tecnico
loro e perché hai io per schierò il
color arancione costa qui ancora bensì
di perdere la ragione
eh sì perché un pianoro diventa un bel
colore acceso e tu io penso comunque che
pescherò qualche verde rovinerà tutto ma
spero ancora di pescare qualche rotta
non venga rotto il tavolo pronti calata
formiche sasso è mai cominciato questa
volta mi raccomando fare brutti scherzi
non ti preoccupare
[Musica]
mi piace questa canzone reinventate alla
canzone del tacchino messa qui non lo
spacchino e poi come sa come sono un
tacchino e pollo e il progetto per
pescare ma pensi bene perché non pensare
bene perché già ultimo turno invece io
vado così a caso che ho preso io non
posso dire niente per la bottiglia
grande quindi potrebbe essere anche
l'arancione e il rosso
comunque vada sarà una troppo contenta
la chiesa non colore e pellissier
voglio portare alla tua faccia
d'arancione lo so come ma che si sta per
l'offerta del colore del tuo film e
contenuti mischia mischio per bene ok
fino alla radice del merde non si è
fatta sentire quindi forse andrà tutto
bene non si è fatta sentire ancora
[Musica]
secondo me hai messo i colori che non mi
piacciono sempre al centro perché pensi
io pesti sempre dal centro e immesso i
colori che mi piacciono lontano ma se da
questo o da questa parte se ne yo messi
fa ballare quelli belli quelli belli
sento troppo silenzio
di sicuro di voler prendere quello
secondo mezzo di caridà il tuo silenzio
è un bel colore e ti dispiace che dopo è
stato vero paura nostra se cambiamo la
teca queste rose gold che col tuo
marroncino starà benissimo
la brawn capisco cosa è una torta di
arancione ranchino arancioni secondo la
radio lo so che colore rosso brutto
veramente bello ci sta bene perché per
l'altra intero guarda uscirà bellissimo
che non ho pescato nessun verdetto
diverso però c'era anche qui anche qui
poi c'era anche qui almeno abbiamo
innescato nessuno che sarebbe stato
meglio converta secondo me no vediamo
allora i giovani ecco qua questo è il
mio colore
secondo voi che colore è brutto sembra
un color pesca nascano queste ramente
bellissimo ci sta bene nel mio perché
tutto è bloccato il perlato per la
mancata perché è diventato veramente una
torta di rose gold sono felicissima di
questi colori era troppo brutto guardo
era molto il bellissimo sinistra geloso
perché super metallizzata superman le
tre e mezza il tuo è un colore ma dove
rimane comunque un brutto i miei anche
glitter il turno abbiamo un po
diventeranno semplicissimo climber rosso
con niente di speciale nel vero lo
voglio fare l'arancione comunque
arancione marotta ma io mi metto poco
non avete crediamo a uno slide mio
decido io
vediamo se migliora o è diventato un
bellissimo
aspetta aspetta arancione bellissima
a casa quasi chiese veramente salsa
aurora salsa cotta dopo il montatore
arriva lo slime che il top come te che
dei ratei giacché bellissimo no non è
che certo guardare arancione si vede
bene gara sono gelosa e non solo perché
il mio amico e mi remando più belle
alberghiero del carattere di un colore
bello acceso dal rosso fuoco ma non
troppo un po arancione non come duo che
il tuo link sembra una terra scaduta e
mi è preziosa e ora lo vedremo attivato
siamo rotti frantini marino altri place
liberare di vederli attendere la prima 3
2 col mio slime gornati ammirato in
poche parole su pen
beh guarda un po e metallizzato e
parlato se proprio uno slam prezioso e
poi ancora un pochino pensato perché non
volevo attivarlo troppo comunque a di
glitter oro vedete anche delle sfumature
oro perché avevamo messo il colorante
oro comunque alla fine sono stata
fortunata perché ho beccato tutti i
colori perlati e metallizzati che fanno
benissimo di m il colore secondo perché
colore è questo brutto ora mi sembra una
sorta di bronzo un po aranciato canzone
che sentiamo ora un po di suoni smr
[Musica]
allora anche i suoli sono fantastici
quindi questo è il mio slide che in nome
di do lo chiamo slime metallizzato reato
realtà va bene sei metallizzato video
ora quella di evitare semi ma è bello il
mio
la più sito arancione è già riuscito
bellissimo guardate è spettacolare e
fantastico come potete vedere anche il
mio dei riflessi oro ma non è vero o no
cioè nel senso di riflessi pomodoro
sempre coloro che ne dice vedere che non
può dire che si muovono in questa
arancione è molto bello mi piace un
sacco
mi chiamo i rumori pochi invece ti amo
le bollicine un pochettino ci sono detto
che è bello elastico ma non troppo
infatti dista già senza saper cavare
bene ovvero pacchi gruppo o ricaribili
devo dire che il colore è uscito molto
calcio che si è davvero bello e razza
calcolare non è vero ma anche dei
bellissimi sole mio la cosa più lette mr
eccoli qua
chi vince è difficile ma male difficile
agilissimo vinco io vinco io non ho
attaccato tutta la stampa ha votate
merito dato a kimi inter via quando ha
lasciato per mi piace per altri talent
prime e ora mi lascia un po a quota
castellini su cui cliccare cliccate su
quella che preferite e buona visione
ciao